dimanche le rituel est immuable bernard
michel sur la distribution du journal
pour une poignée d'habitants du hameau
des lices jusque là rien de très
original
si ce n'est qu'à 80 13 ans bernard me
chier certainement le plus vieux vendeur
de journaux de toute la france ça fait
depuis 1985 que montmagny mon épouse un
repli la septième saison de sa mère qui
tenait le café en face
cet ancien agriculteur fait l'admiration
d'une clientèle toujours fidèle tous les
dimanches matins je vais chercher mon
journal c'est une habitude depuis
plusieurs années on se connaît depuis
très très longtemps et puis moi j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour lui et il faut
dire que bernard mich est un peu l'âme
du village
il l'a vu se transformer au cours des
décennies passées
ma femme m'a été dit et aide ici mais
moi je suis rivalisent en 1951
mais alors comment il a changé de visage
enfin beaucoup
avant il y avait honnêteté je prend
combien une dizaine d'agriculteurs
maintenant il n'y en a plus qu'un ou
deux et puis c'est tout les dh this
qu'on vous riez là où des essais les
lits des résidences secondaires sa fille
également habitante du hameau est très
heureuse de le voir poursuivre cette
activité familiale c'est c'est continuer
ce cas maman faisait aussi donc voila et
puis ça lui permet de voir un petit peu
quelques personnes bernard michel espère
pouvoir continuer sa petite distribution
encore de nombreuses années
un moyen pour lui de rester en contact
avec la vie du village